لا يغيب الامل عن من بقي حيا فوق الارض
ليتمسك من هو عالق تحتها بخيط حياه الرفيع
[تصفيق]
ايام تمر وناجون ينهضون من تحت الابنيه
المنهاره هنا يشيرون اليها بالمعجزات
يرشدنا فرحات الى مبنى انهار على ساكنين
وهو كان منهم بقي عالقا تحت الركام نحو
ثلاثه عشره ساعه
مروعه كان يسمع خلالها اصوات اقاربه
استغيث ولم يسمعني احد رغم انني كنت اسمع
الضجيج في الخارج اللهم نحني القوه للصمود
وان اخرج حيا انها معجزه وفقدت تحت
الانقاض شقيقي وشقيقتي في موقع قريب يحاول
الرجال الانقاذ سحب شخص من تحت الانقاض لا
نعرف ان كان على قيد الحياه
قصص ملهمه شهدنا عليها في زلزال كهرمان
مراش دفعتنا الى التساؤل ما الذي يساعد
الانسان على البقاء على قيد الحياه وسط
مشهد الدمار الكبير هذا وانعدام فرص
الحياه تحت الانقاض واستمرار الهزات
الارتداديه والبرد الشديد حملنا السؤال
الى فريق انقاذ مختص بالتعامل مع العالقين
الاحياء تحت الانقاض حجم المكان حيث يوجد
الشخص الناجي وشده الاصابه من العوامل
التي تلعب دورا في الصمود تحت الانقاض
ليبقى الجفاف هو التهديد الاخطر
محظوظين لاننا في الشتاء والطقس بارد وهذا
ما يبقي الاشخاص على قيد الحياه لمده اطول
بخلاف البلدان الاستوائيه والحاره حيث
يصعب البقاء على قيد الحياه لاكثر من
ثلاثه ايام مشاهد جويه تظهر جزءا من حجم
الدمار العظيم الذي لحق بادي يمان
التقديرات الاوليه تش الانهيار اكثر من
2650 مبنى في المدينه
ومئات اخرى ايله للسقوط اما عدد الضحايا
فلا يزال قيد الارتفاع سلام خضر الجزيره
اليمن